salve a tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo video siamo ritornati con il buon
antonello golfini quassù quantum league
allora la cosa che fa ridere che noi due
giochiamo giochi che si chiamano livio
tutti perché sono tutti se non aveva
senso mi piace un sacco il menu abbiamo
già fatto qualche partita per capire
come funziona
cioè io perché lui lo sapeva già vada
parta facciamo vedere che di cosa si
tratta questo capolavoro la chiamo io
prima avevo un personaggio ognuno ha le
sue abilità o cosa no no no no no a ok
sono questioni charter ok
anzi se prendiamo lo stesso diventa un
incubo perché poi non si capisce più
niente chi è esatto comunque ragazzi ve
la spiego io sto sempre pelato comunque
è difficilissimo da spiegare c'è allora
dica lei e secondi si imbattono in
questa maniera qua lo scopo in questa in
questo come si chiama questo tracciato
mannaggia una roba parkour ha fatto la
fine
l'obiettivo è ecco come glielo
spieghiamo quello che sta succedendo
vedrete che noi abbiamo un gol che ha
giocato una partita che si gioca la
seconda ma perché kroos coraggio è
perché ho sbagliato e l'ho preso e sola
morto aiuto non è perché questa cosa fa
cagare e io no vabbè bisogna insisto
buco al centro della mappa so circolo
passati continuano a fare quello che
stava facendo prima esatto e quindi è un
po un casino da spiegare però va bene è
veramente un gioco della madonna
se posso permettermi l'hack è male
non vedo più lei dove ayane solo vedo
ora sono riuscito
non sono riuscito perché sono andato sul
response ma non l'ho preso e ora è
questo è il gioco è difficile da
spiegare e si vince con tre punti in
tutto sto casino madonna ci primo run
john fps puro praticamente giusto jesolo
cecchini trova solo cecchino ho fatto io
6 ma adesso e fa bene quanto vedo non
vedo lei aiuto a maggia ma basta vada
via dalla io dovrei veramente entrare là
dentro ma non lo faccio è manco affatto
tempo a
a dirlo e inoltro colpirla parast ha
nulla e niente del canada di un centro
tutto sto casino sono stato uno stupido
e questo è time extended parte da dove
non ho capito come funziona questo
sinceramente le troviamo l'ultimo il
primo utilizzato e dolore e niente la
ragione lei c'ha ragione non ho capito
però aia e niente non c'è nessuno lo
stesso
niente non c'e nessuna al 100 non si fa
sto punto non ho ancora capito in questo
gioco che io devo non devo ammazzare la
gente ma devo andare al centro e
continua a sparare a gente anche se non
vado nel centro cioè come se il rocket
league prende la palla e corro in giro
per il campo a caso
e niente morto a e non capisco chi va bè
case ucciso da solo ma come vi sono ci
sono e si è stato il suo possesso ad
ucciderla e allora ce n'erano
mara si si si oh se stesso sì sì madonna
il casino tropez inguardabile non si
capisce niente battutissima questa
estate mannaggia no eni ed esso non ho e
non posso dire sparare non ci sono più
sponsor oppure evento così ma questo
cosa stai facendo in tutto questo che io
non sto capendo più niente
si può anche sparare a cazzo
preventivando è in è quello che facevo
io prima però non sto capendo non sto
capendo io non sto capendo niente
dell'oblio giuro miur gatto che non
capiscono cosa devo fare dove devo
andare
ma come ed è sin crema ha fatto e poi
non ci sono più gli spot quadri sono
pilar non è più la non c'è più la vita
questo è rimasto vivo e la seconda
partita stiamo andando a farti una
mezz'ora e va bene niente niente
e niente non solo buono era meglio
rocket league
sì molto carino facciano un'altra dove
cerco di capire che bisogna andare nel
centro proprio sembra fatto veramente da
dio è molto interessante se chi giorno
signorili pochi ma già in due persin due
interisti di docenti di due come fire è
il 4 diventa per la tosta e nomi che non
si capisce più niente che ho fatto
quattro però tutti con lo stesso
personaggio sapeva niente è madonna
ancora una volta sparo i dalit martire
non è ha già fatto arrestarsi no no ok
e questo è un bel vantaggio ayala ha
fatto un grave errore ma porto così
densa più e si in mezzo ai a questo è
successo non mi hanno invece dovuto
dirmelo
al che fu dio ok
su madonna si capisce niente no ma sono
riuscito a belhaj peccato quello sotto
mamma mia che casino senza capire come
si gioca tutto questo quindi adesso lei
sa che io andrò in mezzo però a start e
niente è enorme e proprio stata è
proprio un karma del tempo esatto quindi
lei sapeva che io avrei sarei morto
prima madonna al casinò madonna come
sono avanti jesi lei avanti sì eccola
[Musica]
niente però lei mi ha sconfitto adesso è
però è perché ma mi ha asfaltato tuttore
su tre è perché sapevo che lei spa una
vallata che il cecchino è buono ma se
sbagli e si della baia finita se noi
abbiamo avuto la stessa idea per vederci
l'altro su questo casino e non riescono
stesso io sono veramente una persona
irrecuperabile e non sono riuscito
volevo fare una roba e non sono riuscito
a farla
volevo uccidere l'altro che era rimasta
poca vita prima però l'ho ucciso lei
adesso però lei avuto il tempo di andare
a curarsi impossibile a dio e lo sapevo
mannaggia
no mi ha fregato piccoli dice arrivo no
ci arrivavo a 1 a 1 è perché io ci
terminale per il mio isolarle sì ecco
perché una donna che casino
[Musica]
no sono stupido ma ancora stupido aiuto
ma no ero rimasto solo io
mannaggia da due romani che va bene
niente
e va bene doveva o no volevo fare una
cosa incredibile città dunque si
misurasse colpirmi da sempre niente si
farà un casino questo come threesixty lo
scopo è per niente se è niente che
potesse curare lì né lo so mi dimentico
ma lei mi ha saltato un razzo
all'indietro nel tempo pazzesco
lei e matrix non lo so
ma dai no la mia natura non mi ha
sbucciato l'arma non mi ha svelato
l'arcano devo ricaricare ha fatto che è
già capito cos è il record si mannaggia
a me sarebbe bella bella questa è stata
la più bella perché questo è più o meno
ho capito cos'è successo per nome
fighissimo dai ragazzi ringrazio signor
gatto è stato
devo leggere un due tre libri per
recuperare un po di sanità mentale o
persona tante ci sia preso le tante più
di quanto un link iscritti al canale
ciao a tutti
[Musica]